mardi soir c'était la cérémonie
d'ouverture du 62e festival de cannes
nat se classant 15e festival de cannes
ouvert alors si à l'époque sur canal+ le
festival de cannes ça ressemblait à ça
des gens on est activée ouais
maintenant sur france télévisions il ya
juste daphné bürki solo sur un plateau
et qui nous promet de grandes choses
vous aurez accès à absolument tout et
oui sauf dans dix ans elle ne
s'attendait pas à ce que son envoyé
spécial louise ekland soit aura sera
totale sur les marches alors il faut que
jeunesse romain parti remercie beaucoup
de répondre à nos questions à il paraît
que vous avez une question
est celle qu'il fallait absolument avoir
à son micro c'était apparemment julianne
moore et j'ai pu échanger avec elle ah
bah enfin une bonne nouvelle alors
voyons tout de suite à quoi ressemble
cet échange tu viendras boliviens ont
connu des séries et
ben ça valait le coup d'attendre pendant
trois heures en plein cagnard c'est le
yes le plus chic de l'univers à part ça
comme chaque année du beau monde sur le
tapis rouge comme eva longoria ou gérard
jugnot mais ce sont forrest whitaker et
vincent lindon qui ont amené les
hommages du public
même si après dix minutes de standing
ovation il savait plus trop quoi faire
sur scène
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors quand même c'est un c'est un
succès d'audience sur canal c'est plutôt
une niche ça des 470 milles de mémoire
avec la c 1 million s'est donc séparé ou
plutôt pas mal vous avez aimé la
cérémonie oui non plus pauvres car c'est
un succès d'audience parce que c'est sur
france 2 mais c'est plus un événement le
festival de cannes sauf qu'à l'époque où
il y avait le grand journal valérie jc
ça irait rendre sa populaire là pardon
mais c'est un petit monde celle entre
eux soit qu'ils qui célèbre le cinéma je
pense que ça n'intéresse plus grand
public lassé diffusée sur une grande
chaîne donc mécaniquement ça fait
l'audience mais ce n'est plus un
événement c'est quand même il est quand
même le premier marché mondial des pc
premier festival je trouve que c'est
moins l'événement qu'à l'époque du grand
journal il ya tout un tas de
manifestations parallèles quand même un
certain regard la caméra d'or etc c'est
extrêmement intéressant moi j'ai moi je
suis allé pendant vingt ou trente ans je
crois j'ai toujours été niée calisesi
parce que vous n'êtes pas comédien
s'est tournée captain marleau récemment
tu es gentil toi tu vois c'est vrai oui
alors c'est bien pas d'autres comédiens
d'apprendre que vous que vous
c'était le dernier sur la liste avec
tous ces clubs qui ont causé sa d'un
festival de marque je peux vous dire ici
les hôtels qui coûtent une fortune vous
êtes logé deux jours après vous dégagez
bernard l'hôtel on est bien logé à
ces savoureux tout mais bien sûr il
passe je m'en tape faire des films c'est
ben oui comme j'ai mis les pieds alors
quoi qu'on en dise était quand même
depuis deux ans il n'y a pas eu de
festival n'y avait pas de ça et quand
même l'arrivée de tom cruise
ces cas là voilà l'idée la batterie de
france il fait passer au dessus du
palais des festivals et quand ils
arrivent mais il a fait quoi il s'est
inspiré d'un animateur télé est arrivé
en hélicoptère
benjamin car c'est mon intimité tout
regarder
donc pour son retour et vue il n'a pas
fait les choses à moitié la patrouille
de france a survolé la croisette au
moment de la montée des marches
oui le regard émerveillé de tom cruise
alors ça c'est les images de la fin de
journée mais fois que je raconte quand
même toute la journée arrivée de tom
cruise en début d'après midi je vous le
donne en mille un hélicoptère l'idée
sans tranquillement rire mais sa veste
mais pour lui arrivé en hélicoptère
c'est la base quand il arrivait tom
cruise a été la folie ça si on se rend
compte à quel point c'est un acteur
populaire les gens scandé son nom
alors il est pilote de son hélicoptère
tiens c'est un gars doux c'est un très
bonne équipe terre c'est sûr mais alors
j'ai un petit bémol à l'heure où on
parle quand même d'écologie de
protection de la planète je trouve que
arrivé en hélicoptère - le sport
on n'est pas donné à tous parce que ça
peut lui est là on prend pas la grosse
vie en bateau et aux moyens mais six
mois pour le festival d'occase
bloquant mais bon ça va je vais je vais
je peux vous dire son programme il est
arrivé en hélico parce qu'il est arrivé
en jet privé à l'ariane
après direct hélico après il a été se
changer dans l'hôtel majestic il a
répondu la fine master class il a fait
les photos pour la presse après le sort
il a monté les marches et il est reparti
directement dans son avion privé pour
assister au jubilé de ta copine et si le
chi minh et a subi l'effet est à blâmer
fait le tour du monde et des montées les
dérangements ça fait rêver voilà
bien conservée pour 60 ans on voit mais
c'est bien avec le bac 6 milliards soir
alors la première parisienne et les
magnifiques à vous étiez invité ben
cherche invités jamais invité sur
europe 1 un film paramount bref c'est un
film européen donc comme travaille pour
le groupe lagardère n'en est rien et
vous êtes deux heures scotché à votre
siège et leur extrême sous les a vu le
premier à les spectaculaires tessema
violèrent allait faire formant merci